what's up guys we're pongfinity today
we're trying out wheelchair table tennis
[Applause]
it's easy if you play to one spot
[Applause]
oh yes
oh
that's coming
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we had a session with our friend aino
toppola who is one of the world's best
wheelchair table tennis players
in her class she showed us some of the
main tactics and shots in wheelchair
table tennis and now we're gonna try
them out
in wheelchair table tennis the serve
isn't allowed to come off the side of
the table
so the best serves are a really short
one or a long fast one
no you see that's not very good
the best shot in wheelchair table tennis
is a short backspin that returns to your
own side
it's very difficult for the opponent to
reach
[Applause]
yes okay let's try playing some points
against aina let's see how it goes
hey i just got the one in the corner
[Music]
[Applause]
it's so tactically different it was
easier against you
[Music]
i'm wrong way around even in wheelchair
table tennis i'm doing a lot of
extra movement
[Music]
[Music]
too slow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
impossible yeah that was good hope you
guys found this video
interesting and let us know in the
comments below if you want to see a
point find the wheelchair tournament
until next time